تناثرت جثامين عشرات الشهداء في شوارع حي
الشيخ رضوان شمالي مدينه غزه وظلت ملقاه
على قارعه الطرق
لايام وبعد استكمال قوات الاحتلال
انسحابها من الحي تكشف حجم الدمار الهائل
الذي اصاب المباني السكنيه والمرافق
الصحيه والمؤسسات جراء القصف الذي استمر
طوال اسابيع التقرير التالي يستعرض وجها
من اوجه العدوان الاسرائيلي على الشيخ
رضوان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انسحابها
من حي الشيخ رضوان بالكامل تاركه خلفها
دمارا هائلا وواسعا كما تشاهدون هذه
العياده الوحيده التي كانت تخدم المواطنين
جعلتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كومه
خراب وهنا ايضا في محيطها الحرائق كما
تشاهدونها منتشره في كل
مكان
هذا مفترق السوق قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ايضا دمرت هذه المكان كما تشاهدون تدميرا
كبيرا هنا كانت كان تجمعا
للاليات
الاسرائيليه انا اول مره بتفرج على
المنطقه هذه حجم دمار
و يعني الله يعين كل واحد ضاره تهدمت
وبيته تهدمت وربنا يرفع ان شاء الله ربنا
هيك تخلص الحرب وترجع الحياه لاول ان شاء
الله واحسن اليهود دمرونا خربوا كل شش ما
نملك في الحياه ولا عارفين نقعد في دار
ولا عارفين نقعد في شارع وقاعدين بنعبي
ميه مندور المكسوفه يعني حجم الدمار عننا
في الشارع دمار هائل ما خوش لنا مكان
نتاوى فيه مناطق الاواء دمروها اللي كنا
قاعدين فيها هذه مدرسه الموهبين التي كانت
تؤوي الاف النازحين سوتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالارض هنا على مقربه من هذه
المدرسه كما تشاهدون جثمان شهيد قد تحلل
في هذا
المكان بعد ان منعت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انتشال جثامين الشهداء او
الوصول الى هذه المنطقه كانت تستهدفهم
بطات الاستطلاع وبالقناعه هنا جثمان شهيد
متحلل في هذا
الحي وسط هذا الخراب
[موسيقى]
الكبير هذا هو سوق الشيخ رضوان دمرته قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالكامل هنا هذه
الساحه كانت مجمعا للاليات العسكريه ما
نتج عن ذلك تدميرا للمكان برمته وهذا هو
السوق وتفاصيله كما تشاهدونه الان مدمرا
تدميرا كاملا وهو كان يخدم
الاف من سكان هذا الحي وهو السوق الوحيد
فيه هنا ايضا في محيط سوق الشيخ رضوان كما
تشاهدون جثامين الشهداء في الشوارع تتكشف
بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
هذا المكان ايضا هنا مزيدا من جثامين
الشهداء كما تشاهدون هذا الشهيد ملقى على
الارض منذ ايام وبدا يتحلل وايضا هنا شهيد
اخر كما تشاهدون من هؤلاء المواطنين الذين
كانوا يحاولون الوصول الى منازلهم لكن
استهدفتهم قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالقذائف وطائرات الاستطلاع جثم الشهداء
على الطرقات منتشره في هذا الحي المنكوب
الذي دمرته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هنا
القطط تحاول كما تشاهدون نهش من جثمان هذا
الشهيد وهو ملقى على الارض منذ ايام كباقي
الشهداء في هذا الحي هنا ايضا شهيد اخرين
على على ملقى على قارعه الطريق كما
تشاهدون كما عدمته قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كباقي الشهداء واطلقت والقته
في الشوارع هذا هو شهيد مسن كما تشاهدون
ملقى على
الارض